hello i am mathias and the founder of
datatep
in this video i will explain everything
about the level of measurement
in a simple way the level of measurement
is one of the most important properties
of variables
and statistics it is important because
it defines
set out arithmetic operations and thus
defines the possible statistical tests
the higher the scale level the more
statistical tests are possible
the level of measurement of a variable
can be either nominal scale
ordinal scale or matric in short
for nominal variables the values can be
differentiated
so we can differ between a b c
and d for ordinary variables the values
can be sorted
a is smaller than b b is smaller than c
and c is smaller than d and further for
matrix scale levels the distances
between the values can be calculated
and now we will have a closer look at
each of the scale levels
the nominal level of measurement is the
lowest level of measurement in
statistics
and therefore has the lowest information
content
possible values of the variables can be
distinguished
but a meaningful order is not possible
therefore the characteristics of nominal
variables are
only relations equal and unequal are
possible
there's no logical ranking of categories
the order of the onsite categories is
interchangeable
nominal characteristics with only two
expressions
are called binary or dichetone for
example
a nominal variable is the gender the
marital status
or your preferred newspaper in the case
of gender you have the characteristics
male and female in the case of some
marital status we have
single married divorced or widowed
and what is your preferred newspaper it
could be the washington post
the new york times or us today
in all these examples you can
distinguish between the categories
but it is not possible to define a
ranking
the ordinary level of measurement is the
next higher level it contains
nominal information only with the
difference that a ranking
can be formed therefore the term ranking
scale
is often used in this case however the
distances
between the values are not interpretable
so it is not possible to make a
statement
about the absolute distance between two
values
therefore the characteristics are it is
the next higher level of measurement
it is possible to determine equal and
unequal categories
and greater or smaller there is a
logical hierarchy of categories
the distances between the numerical
values are not equal
therefore they cannot be interpreted for
example
ordinary variables can be frequency of
television
or the question the government is doing
a good job in the first case frequency
of television the groups are
daily several times a week less
frequently
or never so you can distinguish between
these
answers and it is possible to rank them
the same we will have for this question
the government is doing a good job
agree with undecided or declines
therefore compared to the nominal scale
we have also
categories which can be distinguished
but further it is possible
to rank them now let's have a closer
look at the last level of measurement
matrix variables have the highest
possible level of measurement
with a matrix level of measurement the
characteristic values
can be compared and sorted and distances
between the values can be calculated
so the characteristics are it is the
highest level of measurement
it is possible to create rankings equal
and unequal
is possible and for sure it is possible
to define which value is greater
and smaller and differences in sums can
be formed meaningfully
as an example for matrix variables we
have the income
the weight the age and the electricity
consumption
the matrix scale level can be further
subdivided into interval scale
and ratio scale to understand the
difference
let's look at these the example for the
ratio scale
the time of marathon runners is measured
here the statement can be made
that the fastest runner is twice as fast
as the last runner
this is possible because there's an
absolute zero point at the beginning of
the marathon
where all runners start from zero now we
will come to the example of the interval
scale
if however the stopwatch is forgotten to
start at the start of the marathon
and only the differences are measured
starting from the fastest runner
the runners cannot be put into
proposition in this case it can be said
how big the interval between the runners
is for example runner a
is 22 minutes faster than runner b but
it cannot be said that runner a
ran 20 faster than runner b this is only
possible if you have an absolute zero
point
but in this case we don't have this i
hope you get a good feeling about the
level of measurement
and now we will have a look at this
exercises
if you like please stop the video and go
through the table
by your own we will go through the
answers now
the first point states of the usa this
is
the nominal scale level product rating
on a scale from 1 to 5.
this is an ordinal scale religious
confession
this is an nominal scale co2 emission in
the year
for sure status and matrix scale iq of
students
this is also a matrix scale examination
grades from one to five
this is an ordinal scale the telephone
number
that is a nominal scale the care level
of patients
this is an ordinal scale living space in
square meters
this is a matrix or ratio scale shop
satisfaction on the scale from one to
five
this is an ordinal scale
now you know how to handle the level of
measurement if you don't know data tab
yet
just google data tab on data tab you
will find
great tutorials and you can easily
calculate your data
online with data tab if you want to be
informed as soon as there's a new video
of mine
just subscribe to the channel and click
on the bell
thanks and see you soon bye